good morning Hank it's Tuesday who drew
it daddy or Henry daddy it's question
Tuesday the day that I answer real
questions from real nerdfighters but
first a story so Mike almost every
morning I wake up with a song in my head
also you might remember that I once
described tumblers being comprised
primarily of homoerotic wholock
watercolors okay so then my Dutch
friends water and lead if I wrote a song
about it for me and this morning I woke
up and I was walking around and I was
singing homoerotic water colors are just
one thing I love they do not define me
you should know and then I woke up at
the living room at Henry's babysitter
was there and she was like what but it's
true that by the way I just looked down
and I was like Fried Chicken here in the
morning what have I done to deserve this
but it turns out is play chicken it's so
weird having a toddler right it's
question Tuesday but I've to go into the
office which means the quality of this
video is about to improve significantly
favorite part of the evening of awesome
the part where all of it what would you
most like to tell Esther about I really
wish you could have read The Fault in
Our Stars I think all the time about
whether she would have liked it finish
this sentence it would be a privilege to
have my heart broken by it the answer is
always pizza how do I know if someone
wants to be just friends or more than
friends yeah you should use your words
but wait what do you mean just friends
and more than friends like when did we
hardwired into our language the idea
that the step past friendship is mutual
face licking like the Eddie and I are
more than friends not primarily because
of the face licking aspect of things but
because there are important things that
we share responsibility for like a car
and a mortgage and a human child like
this is Shannon and we live together for
more than five years in our 20s and I
really take offense at the notion that
we're just friends simply because we
never made out I mean Shannon and I have
been together for the worst and best
days of each other's lives we're not
just friends we're not just anything so
yeah you shouldn't say do you want to be
more than friends you should say what
you mean you should say do you want to
be monogamous face licking partners and
yes I realize that not all romantic
relationships involve making out but you
should say what you mean
why is your tumblr called fishing boat
proceeds ever since 2007 I've been
trying to get some fishing boat proceeds
because then you get to check off a
special box on your tax return but it
hasn't happened so I figured maybe
through tumblr but not yet are you ever
afraid of running out of ideas for books
or getting writer's block so crippling
that you never write again yes and thank
you for mentioning it wherefore art thou
Romeo because as I explained in a recent
episode of crash course if he were named
Paris he wouldn't be near
me so hot does Holden Caufield ever
change I'm starting to think you just
aren't subscribed to crash course which
you really should be tiffy OHS movie I
love the script I don't think I'm
allowed to say anything else I'm not
even sure I'm allowed to say that so
just pretend I didn't say anything you
have any tips for a scared parent to be
yeah so at first everyone feels totally
unqualified to be a parent but then you
realize all I have to do is trick this
baby into thinking I'm qualified to be a
parent this is a baby in some cases they
were literally born yesterday they're
super easy to trick nerdfighters whether
you were at Carnegie Hall or watched an
evening of awesome at home thank you so
much it was the highlight of my
professional career Hank thanks for
making it fun and surprisingly relaxing
you are made of awesome I will see you
on Friday